-Now, it is the end of the week,
and that's usually when
I catch up with
some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return emails,
and of course, I send out
thank you notes.
So, I was just wondering,
can I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you so much.
I would like to write out
some thank you notes right now.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Laughter ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
It always works better when
you turn your keyboard on.
[ Laughter ]
Always sounds better when you
turn the keyboard on, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
Thank you, Snoop Dogg,
for releasing
THC-infused Funyuns.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Though, if you're
eating Funyuns,
you're probably
already THC-infused.
That's -- Yeah, I just wonder...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
Thank you, cauldrons,
for meaning you're about to get
one of two things --
a deadly potion,
or tableside guac.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Cool.
[ Applause ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
Thank you, Meta's new
Quest Pro VR headset,
for making everyone look like
my grandma in Boca Raton.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
Thank you, juice press
in my kitchen,
for letting everyone know
there was one day last year
when I thought
I'd get into juicing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm gonna do this every day.
I'm gonna do this every day."
[ Chuckles ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
Thank you, trick-or-treating,
for being the only time you can
knock on a stranger's door,
vaguely threaten them,
and expect candy in return.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Keyboard playing ]
Thank you, opening a bottle
of wine alone,
for being no problem whatsoever.
[ Laughter ]
And thank you,
opening a bottle of wine
in front of other people,
for being the most stressful
moment of my life.
There you have it, everyone.
Those are my thank you notes.